morning John today I want to do
something a little bit different that
might not be appealing to everyone I'm
going to make a video about making
videos and of course if you don't care
about making videos let me do my best to
make it entertaining on the last okay
first let's talk about what I'm not
going to do I'm not going to talk about
your equipment don't care what kind of
camera you have I don't care what kind
of computer you have a wife kind of
software you have this is not about that
I believe that skill is honed by lack
and there's no reason to have a sword
made of Valyrian steel if you're just
learning how to wield a knight so let's
talk first about what's actually
important which is how to look and sound
important thing the rule of thirds
divide your screen into thirds this way
and this way one of the interesting
things about vlogging is the early on
both the eyes and the mouth we're
falling on those lines now that screens
gotten a little bit bigger generally
it's just the eyes that are falling on
the line because the eyes not the mouth
actually are the most important element
of you frame that says something
fundamental about human nature just not
sure what it is now how you sound
imagine for a moment me going downstairs
and talking my wife the way that I talk
while I'm vlogging that does not happen
this is not my normal talking voice
surprise surprise the way that I imagine
it is that I'm on a gigantic stage and
there is one person in the audience and
I'm talking with that one person but I
can't talk to them I could own words
because I'm on a gigantic stage and this
is obviously a difficult thing to hone
you're not going to chew vlogging voice
immediately watch early vlogbrothers
videos and see that we sucked too when
we start a nice that for me the one
person the audience is generally or at
least it started out being my brother I
knew how to talk my brother I knew what
would make him happy now that one person
has changed and it's kind of an amalgam
of all of nerdfighteria it's just each
of you individually I'm trying to
imagine all at once it's very strange
not moving on
there's don't forget to be awesome which
is one of the most important rules in
life's but there's also for vlogging
another one don't forget to begin
teresting I even write out scripts
sometimes so that I make sure that what
I'm saying isn't dull as hell I wrote a
script for this thing I'm going to post
that script on my tumblr so you can see
the difference between script and what
actually gets made into the video also
never forget that even the best audience
there will be parts of it that will have
a very short attention span and you will
have to pander to those people but
honestly it's fun and I've truly
believed that pandering those people
actually makes your video better there's
a lot of ways to keep thing interesting
you can move round put some video over
your voice you can use props
awesome funny hats go outside you can
sing you can sing songs you can speed
things up I can slow things down use
filters and you can use pop it's fun how
people ask me how I get ideas for videos
but really it's not about having ideas
for videos that's easy mostly I'm trying
to figure out how to make those ideas
interest another very important rule
silence is extremely powerful use it
very sparingly if you watch one of my
videos you will notice that there
very few moments that do not have sound
in and that is especially true of the
space around jump cuts any silence
around a jump cut is bad bad bad bad bad
another important rule do not be afraid
to try I know that failing it something
stings a lot less if you didn't really
try hard but it's also much more likely
and finally let's talk about editing no
we're not going to do that because that
would take forever so instead I am
literally going to post a screen capture
of me editing this vlog I'm gonna put
that on my second channel at youtube.com
slash Hanks channel Hanks channel and
you'll be able to see how I made this
video how I did all the tricks I did in
this video with all the things that I do
to make my video blog seem professional
and crisp and good and entertaining and
all of those things so that's how you
vlog of course you can do it however you
want to do it but I think if people
might be interested in seeing how I do
it I encourage all of you to vlog and I
encourage you to do it well the video of
me editing this vlog might not be online
as soon as this goes up on the internet
but it will be online shortly thereafter
and there'll be a link to it in the end
screen John I'll see you on Monday